.
Let's do a few tricky tasks. This tells us that
Nadia is at home and Peter is in a school that is 6 miles away
away from home.
Let me draw a small chart here.
So Nadia is there.
Peter is there and they are 6 miles apart.
So, this is the distance between home and school.
It's 6 miles.
6 miles.
They begin to travel to each other at the same time.
They both leave at the same time traveling
to each other.
Nadia runs at 3 and 1/2 miles per hour.
It moves 3.5 miles in
hour in that direction.
And Peter drives a skateboard with 6 miles in
Peter goes in that direction 6 miles per hour.
When they will meet you and how far away they are from home
the place of their meeting?
Let's say the place of their meeting is right -
I do not know.
It will be closer to home because this boy
moves faster.
Peter moves faster.
So let's say let x be equal to the distance
from home to the place of their meeting.
The distance from home.
So this distance will be x.
So how much will this distance be?
If this is x and the whole thing is 6 miles, then
this distance there will be 6 minus x.
So Nadia will travel x miles, and Peter will
travels 6 minus x miles.
And they will travel the same amount of time.
Remember that they both leave from time 0 and in time t, they
both will meet right there.
So, both will use the same amount of time.
Nadia's equation, if we just do not forget the way is
equal to the speed in time, we could use this for both,
in the case of Nadia, the road she travels is x.
x will be equal to its speed, which is 3.5 miles in
hour, multiplied by t, which is the time it travels.
And then, Peter's equation will be his way.
It travels 6 minus x miles, so it's 6 minus x,
will be equal to its speed, which is 6 miles per hour
the time he travels.
He also travels t hours, so on t.
So, we have two equations and two unknowns, so
we can solve them.
We have already found x here.
So, let's replace that for x there.
We can rewrite this equation as 6 minus, but
instead of x, we can put 3.5t, 6 minus 3.5t because
we know that x is equal to 3.5t, is equal to 6t.
And then let's see if we add 3.5t to both sides of this
equation we get 6 equals 3.5t plus 6t is 9.5t or if
we divide both sides to 9.5, we get t equal to 6 on 9.5
hour, which is a small special number.
But 9.5, we can write this again.
It's the same thing as 6 on - see, 9.5 - that's it
same as 19/2, right?
19/2 by dividing it and getting 9.5.
So, this is equal to 6 in 2 on 19.
So, this is equal to 12/19 of an hour.
That's how long it takes them to meet.
And then, if you ask, at what distance from home
will they meet?
If you want to find the value of x, x will be
equal to 3.5 - in fact, instead of writing 3.5, I can
to write 3.5 as 7/2. This is the same thing as 3.5 - ours
time, on 12/19.
So, divide the numerator and the denominator into 2 and
you get 7 by 6 and 42 for 19 miles.
And this is in hours.
So, after 12/19 of an hour - it's a special liver - they will
meet exactly 42/19 miles from home.
It's just over 2 miles from home.
The next task.
Peter bought a couple of Staples notebooks for $ 2.25.
And he bought a few more notebooks in
Right Aid for $ 2 each.
He has spent the same amount of money in both places and
has bought 17 notebooks in total.
How many notebooks did he buy in each of the two stores?
So let's define some variables.
Let S be equal to the number purchased in Staples.
And then we could say that R is equal to the number purchased
by Wright Eid.
So what do we know?
What do we know?
He bought a total of 17 notebooks.
Let me do this in a different color.
This tells us that S plus R is equal to 17.
We also know that he spent the same amount of money
in both places.
So, how much did he spend on Wright Aid?
Let me do that in orange.
He spent the same amount of money in both places.
So, how much did he spend on Staples?
He bought S notebooks for $ 2.25 each, so 2.25S, that's it
how much he spent at Staplers.
Spent at Staples.
This will be equal to the amount that
has spent at Wade Ad.
He spends $ 2 on a Wright notebook.
$ 2 for a Wright Note notebook.
So, $ 2 on the number of notebooks by Wright Eid,
this is spent in Wright Aid.
Once again, two equations with two unknowns.
Maybe we could make a little substitution here.
What is the best way to substitute here?
Okay, let's share the two sides of it
equation here at 2.
So, you have - I will write again 2.2 - just will
i do it so ..
So, you have R.
If you divide both sides to that of 2, you have 2.25 on
2S is equal to R, right?
I just divided the two sides of this with 2.
So, if you take that value and replace it for R
there, this equation becomes S plus - instead
R, we have 2.25 on 2S is equal to 17.
Let's make it simple.
This is 1 - we can treat it as 2 on 2S, right?
The odds there are only 1.
So, we can see this as if we had one common denominator.
This is the same thing as 4.25 on 2S is equal to 17.
I avoid doing any difficult math yet.
Let's multiply both sides on the contrary.
2 / 4.25.
It 's a bit strange to have expressions at the same time
a fraction and a decimal number, but this is not illegal.
Let's multiply both by 2 / 4.25.
These are canceled and so you get S equals 17 by 2,
is 34 on 4.25.
And in fact, I can see that ...
It seems like this should be equal to 8, right?
4.25 is 4 and 1/4, which is the same as 17 on 4.
So, that's the same thing as 34 on 17/4, which is
the same as 34 in 4/17.
You put 1 there, divided by 17, you get 2, divided by 17,
you get 1, 2 by 4 is 8.
So, he bought 8 notebooks in Staples, that's 8, then
in Wright Eid, bought - 8 plus R equals 17.
You remove 8 from both sides.
He must have bought nine notebooks at Wright Ad.
Let's make one more.
This is especially fun.
Peter is outside watching his pigs
chickens in the yard.
Nadya is inside and can not see the animals.
Peter gives her a mystery.
He tells her that he has counted 13 heads and 36 legs and asks
how many pigs and how many chickens are in the yard.
So, let's redefine our variables.
P equals the number of pigs.
Let C be equal to the number of chickens.
So, the number of chapters will essentially be the number of
pigs and chickens, assuming that each one has one head.
So, the number of pigs plus the number of chickens will be
equal to the number of heads, right here.
This is 13 chapters.
And then 4 on the number of pigs, right?
Each pig has 4 legs, so 4 on the number of pigs plus
2 on the number of chicks, assuming that
we deal with two-legged chickens, will be equal
of the number of legs equals 36.
Once again, we have two equations with two unknowns.
Instead of solving them with a substitution, I will
by collecting and subtracting the two equations.
What we can do, this equation we can
multiply by 2.
And when I say we multiply it by 2, we have to multiply it
the whole equation by 2.
So it's still true.
We multiply the whole equation by 2.
This becomes 2P plus 2C equals 26.
And now what I'm gonna do is get this out
equation of this equation you can do.
Since this is equal to this, it is equal to this and so
we do nothing that violates the laws of the algebra.
So, if you subtract the equation from the above
equation or I can just put a minus sign everywhere
here, so that you know that we take out,
4P minus 2P is 2P.
2C minus 2C is 0.
This is why I did so in order for these to be canceled.
And then 36 minus 26 is equal to 10.
So, 2P equals 10.
We divide the two sides into 2.
We have 5 pigs.
And then, this plus 5 the number of chickens is equal to 13, so
we must have - we get 5 on both sides - 8 chickens.
Now, if this confuses you, you might want to try
with a substitution, but I have a lot of videos to solve systems
from equations, where I drive a bit slower and explain
little more than the logic of that.
So, what is best for you.
But anyway, Nadia must be true or true
to receive 5 pigs and 8 chickens.
And that must be true, is not it?
You have 13 animals.
You have 13 chapters.
And if you multiply 5 by 4, which is 20 pig legs plus 16
chicken legs.
20 plus 16 is 36 feet total.
.